today's question comes from augustus
in kentucky my wife struggles at keeping
our grocery budget
and i don't know how to help her looking
at every dollar in our food budget
including out to eat and groceries
is about an eighth of our total budget
is that enough for two adults with no
kids
is it too much do you have any tips on
deciding what is the right what the
right amount
should be how can i help support her so
we can stick
to our budgets oh well augustus welcome
to every problem
most american households have it's the
food budget
it does i'm like we struggle with this
too it's it's just i'm like one costco
run
can throw us over and i'm like oh my
gosh what like it's hard it really is
food is tough but two adults and no kids
uh and it's an eighth of our budget so
we say about 20 percent
can go to food 10 to 20 depending on
income and situation
um so yeah i mean
well yeah i'm i think you just look at
the amount
and say okay we can't do more than that
or more than this
on this amount of income you know and
you can use a percentage if you want we
have some recommended percentages that
are part of everything
yeah part of the other that that helps
but um
most of the let me let me if you've just
started this process
what i always tell people when i'm
teaching budgeting is whatever you think
you're spending
on money whatever you think you're
spending on food you're wrong
you're spending more and so in order to
get the rest of the budget to work
and everybody happy to work the rest of
the budget
go ahead and be up a little high on the
food budget you're not going to stay
high on the food budget for eight years
you'll quit eventually if every month
you hook up and there's 100
left over in your food budget or 200
left over in your food budget
eventually you'll dial it down and go
well our food budget is really like 100
less i mean it's really what it is
because you'll catch a rhythm and you'll
get to know what's going on
but um i mean a thousand years ago when
the dinosaurs roamed the earth we
started to sat down to do our first
budget sharon and i you were a baby
and i was all game on nerd on this
budget stuff i'm gonna we're gonna do
this we have envelope
with food written on it and you're not
getting any more money than this
and um i think we budgeted like 300
for food now this is 1980 something
right and so we budget
1990 we budget 300 for food well sharon
just
she's like this lady she's like you're
out of your mind you can't do it for
that we have four
we have family of four three you know
two kids you can't do it for that
and i'm like well yeah you can i mean
just don't dispense with that gum much
just get your butt out of the kroger you
know and we got this big argument
yes which you should have and you go
grocery shopping that's what i want him
to do
you know that's exactly that's exactly
what happened ah she said
that from y'all she said all right
genius you go do it
and i said well i will then and i
couldn't and
i went over there and i went oh dead gum
she's right
yeah and so we upped the food budget
back in that day to 500
a month that was a thousand years ago
it'd be 750 in today's dollars
well with family of five that's a lot
yeah but yeah that that was uh uh
i mean we but i was man i was way off
yeah and when i you know so yeah that's
the thing i would tell you
probably uh your wife's not the problem
probably you are like i was and probably
you get your butt
in the car go grocery shopping with her
and start to figure out what this stuff
costs
and you might have some positive some
suggestions
yeah and if you guys are depending on
what baby step you're on to i mean if
you guys are baby steps
one two or three you want to be
realistic about what food
costs but you also don't have the
leisure just to go up and down every
aisle and get whatever you want like no
no no i wasn't suggesting no
i'm just saying for him though i'm
saying even basics you don't know what
they cost
right right but i'm saying to his wife
which
this is more me where i'm like oh yeah
i'm just gonna go see oh that sounds
good i'll just throw that you know i can
i can be a little bit more like that
now you can do that on baby steps for
and on yeah you can enjoy it
but if you're on baby steps one through
three then she may say hey i'm gonna
pull back on some stuff
and i would lose the battle to the tune
of a couple of hundred dollars here
to win the war of getting on the same
page
with your spouse and getting on the same
page and running everything together
yes uh you know and everybody being
happy and you can always dial it back
down later
i mean very few unless unless your wife
is just a twerp i mean
but very few mature people would say
week in and week out month in and month
out
oh i'm just going to hide this money to
the side we're
we've got more in this category than we
need no we we're going to admit that
we're high
right later and bring it back down uh
and we've done that in some categories
around our house the other thing that i
remember the story i remember that
um is i've heard so many people say that
they felt the same way
when we say live like no one else so
later we can live and give like no one
else for sharon
she said someday and you're dreaming you
know we got the yellow pad out we're
trying to pay off the debts we're trying
to get the irs off our back we're
we're working and scratching and clawing
and she said
one of my big dreams is to have enough
money to just go to the grocery store
and fill the buggy with anything i want
and not worry about it yes
now that's a fairly low budget dream at
the end of the day
but that was like to not have to feel so
constrained
worrying about every carton of eggs
we're looking at every every stinking
price on every generic
everything generic cheerios for god's
sakes and
um you know all the stuff and just to be
able to walk in
and buy whatever i want which now for
many many years she's been able to do
and she doesn't have to think about her
grocery budget anymore hasn't in a long
long time
but what what a great um goal to have
okay so something else i thought of
augustus if you're listening when i was
doing research on my book know yourself
know your money i was talking about
safety versus status and all that and
interviewing people with the safety
mindset a lot of women
said there's a comfort of having a full
fridge or a full pantry yeah
there's something emotional about
especially if they came from a home
where
food was a struggle yes so there there
could be a safetyness
there that she feels the need to have if
she doesn't have you know if she's not
cutting back
and she is buying a little bit more than
maybe you guys need necessarily there
could be
an emotional safety aspect of that and
so to kind of dig into that and look to
say okay are there other places that we
can have that security
and maybe save a little bit on the food
budget but it's amazing how many women
i talked to who said i if i have a full
fridge i feel like okay i'm good
yeah like it's yeah yeah there's
something about it it's like an
emergency fund yeah there's an emotional
thing to it especially if you have kids
and all that well
it's a uh uh nesting thing you know just
to make sure that your family's fed
yes i know my family's father i know my
family's fed yeah and uh just very very
important
so your food budget um will
change a little between baby steps one
two three
and then later on you can relax it a
little bit in four five six
but it's not going to change a ton one
other thing you may find in your food
budget that you can do
is when we started out we had two
separate envelopes
one for restaurants and one for
groceries so that we didn't go to the
restaurant and eat the grocery money
because you can do that really easily oh
yeah and keep those categories separate
and if you're in one two and three
you shouldn't be in a restaurant anyway
you should be getting out of debt you
should be eating at home and cooking
from home and
uh you know saving the money and so but
but yeah
i think if you some of you guys i mean i
haven't done it in a long long time but
truth be told one of the biggest fights
we ever had back in the early days of
starting the stuff that we teach
was over that stinking food envelope and
she threw it at me
you go do it then genius and so i'm like
i will so i go over there the unstable
money classroom years
yeah i go i go over there and i couldn't
do it and so then we went back together
and i watched really how good a job she
was doing yeah
to her credit and to my shame because i
had tried to shame her into doing you
know and living on absolutely nothing
that wouldn't
wasn't possible the numbers i was trying
to make all the numbers work and that
was just one of the categories
there was a problem you know but it
didn't uh man it you nerds you've got to
be careful with this
whoever does the shopping if your
husband does a shopping you know ladies
you can't you can't
you got to go and get a little bit of
that in there that's right especially
when you're starting you don't have to
do it forever but it gets everybody in a
rhythm gets everybody on the same page
and that's just really
really important